the bold design masked big tobacco's
controversial past here surrounded by
tobacco plants the world's biggest
cigarette company is trying to reinvent
itself Philip Morris has poured three
and a half billion pounds into this
complex of labs where scientists some
from the pharmaceutical industry are
innovating what they believe is safer
tobacco for a smoke-free future and Sky
News was given unprecedented access if
we stop now selling cigarettes somebody
else is going to sell them because
people buy them so I don't think I would
have any impact on public health or on
the health of people and at the end of
the day the ambition we have is to
replace cigarettes as soon as possible
with better alternatives obviously for
the people continue smoking and for that
I think we really put our money where
our wishes and mouth is it's already
released I caused an electric device
that heats tobacco rather than burning
it and on a machine that acts like an
artificial lung scientists can compare
it with a standard cigarette even to the
untrained eye the difference is clear so
here we have the pad that has collected
the smoke of the cigarette and here we
have the pad that has collected the
aerosol cycles we look in this
laboratory here on a routine basis at 15
different cancer-causing chemicals that
are present in cigarette smoke with IKOS
aerosol there are more than 95% reduced
but long-term studies haven't yet been
done to prove that means the device is
safer than cigarettes nor has the
company compared it with vaping public
health England says there just isn't
enough evidence on the risks and
benefits of heated tobacco products and
he wants more independent research
Philip Morris says that it's got nothing
to hide and it wants outside scientists
to come and look at its data but it
raises a fundamental question would you
trust big tobacco smoking killed 100
million people worldwide in the 20th
century yet for decades the industry
denied there was a risk yes everyone can
turn over a new leaf but this is an
industry that has behaved worse and the
outcomes have being worse than any other
i mean its killed millions it will kill
millions more this century it's all very
well talking about a smoke-free future
but I have yet to see the evidence that
convinces me that that's really what
they're going for smoking rates are
falling in richer countries as people
quit or switch to vaping so products
like I cost could be a shrewd business
move a reason for smokers to stick with
tobacco in some form but not all are
convinced these are scrambling it's just
the only one there's money at the end of
the day I mean they don't care about
your health aren't like that I think
it's more of a matter of ticking ticking
boxes because they have a duty of care
they know they produce a product that is
dangerous for the health of people I
think it's just you know free markets
and giving more choice to consumers
really I think it's a good thing come to
where the flavor is come to Marlboro
country
rubra man made philip morris rich but it
wants a third of its customers to give
up cigarettes by 2025 to do that it
first has to win back trust Thomas More
Sky News new Chatel in Switzerland